so I'm at Radio glaciologist and that
means that I use radar to study glaciers
and ice sheets and like most
glaciologists right now I'm working on
the problem of estimating how much the
ice is going to contribute to sea level
rise in the future so today I want to
talk to you about why it's so hard to
put good numbers on sea level rise and
why I believe that by changing the way
we think about radar technology and
earth science education we can get much
better at it so when most scientists
talk about sea level rise they show a
plot like this this is produced using
ice sheet and climate models on the
right you can see the range of sea level
predicted by these models over the next
hundred years for context this is
current sea level and this is the sea
level above which more than four million
people could be vulnerable to
displacement so in terms of planning the
uncertainty in this plot is already
large however beyond that this plot
comes with the asterisks and the caveat
unless the West Antarctic Ice Sheet
collapses and in that case we wouldíve
talking about dramatically higher
numbers they'd literally be off the
chart and the reason we should take that
possibility seriously is that we know
from the geologic history of the earth
that there were periods in its history
when sea level rose much more quickly
than today and right now we cannot rule
out the possibility of that happening in
the future so why can't we say with
confidence whether or not a significant
portion of a continent scale ice sheet
will or will not collapse well in order
to do that we need models that we know
include all of the processes conditions
and physics that would be involved in a
collapse like that and that's hard to
know because those processes and
conditions are taking place beneath
kilometers of ice and satellites like
the one that produced this image are
blind to observe them in fact we have
much more comprehensive observations of
the surface of Mars than we do of what's
beneath
an article sheet and this is even more
challenging in that we need these
observations at a gigantic scale in both
space and time in terms of space this is
a continent and in the same way that in
North America the Rocky Mountains
Everglades and Great Lakes regions are
very distinct so are the subsurface
reasons of Antarctica and in terms of
time we now know that ice sheets not
only evolved over the timescale of
millennia and centuries but they're also
changing over the scale of years in days
so what we want is observations beneath
kilometers of ice at the scale of a
continent and we want them all the time
so how do we do this well we're not
totally blind to the subsurface I said
in the beginning that I was a radio
glaciologist and the reason that that's
a thing is that airborne ice-penetrating
radar is the main tool we have to see
inside of ice sheets so most of the data
that's used by my group is collected by
airplanes like this world war ii era
dc-3 that actually fought in the Battle
of the Bulge you can see the antennas
underneath the wing these are used to
transmit radar signals down into the ice
and the echoes that come back contain
information about what's happening
inside and beneath the ice sheet while
this is happening scientists and
engineers are on the airplane for eight
hours at a stretch making sure that the
radars working and I think this is
actually a misconception about this type
of field work where people imagine
scientists peering out the window
contemplating the landscape it's
geologic context in the fate of the ice
sheets we actually had a guy from the
BBC's frozen planet on one of these
flights and he spent like hours
videotaping us turn knobs and I was
actually watching the series years later
with my wife and a scene like this came
up and I commented on how beautiful it
was and she said weren't you on that
flight
I said yeah but I was looking at a
computer screen so so when you think
about this type of fieldwork don't think
about images like this think about
images like this this is a radar gram
which is a vertical profile through the
ice sheet kind of like a slice of cake
the bright layer on the top is a surface
of the ice sheet the bright layer on the
bottom is the bedrock of the continent
itself and the layers in between are
kind of like tree rings and that they
contain information about the history of
the ice sheet and it's amazing that this
works this well the ground-penetrating
radar that are used to investigate
infrastructures of roads or detect
landmines struggle to get through a few
meters of earth and you're repairing
through three kilometers of ice and are
sophisticated interesting
electromagnetic reasons for that but
let's say for now that ice is basically
the perfect target for radar and radar
is basically the perfect tool to study
ice sheets so these are the flight lines
of most of the modern airborne radar
sounding profiles collected over
Antarctica this is the result of heroic
efforts over decades by teams from a
variety of countries and international
collaborations and when you put those
together you get an image like this
which is what the continent of
Antarctica would look like without all
the ice on top and you can really see
the diversity of the continent and an
image like this the red features are
volcanoes or mountains there's that are
blue the open ocean if the ice sheet was
removed this is that giant spatial scale
however all of this that took decades to
produce is just one snapshot of the
subsurface it does not give us any
indication of how the ice sheet is
changing in time
now we're working on that because it
turns out that the very first radar
observations of Antarctica were
collected using 35 millimeter optical
film and there were thousands of reels
of this film and the archives of the
Museum of the Scott Polar Research
Institute at the University of Cambridge
so last summer I took a state of the art
film scanner that was developed for
digitizing Hollywood films and
remastering them into art historians and
we went over to England put on some
gloves and archive and digitized all of
that film so that produced 2 million
images high-resolution images that my
group is now
working on analyzing and processing for
comparing with contemporary conditions
in the ice sheet and actually that
scanner I found out about it from an
archivist at the Academy of Motion
Pictures Arts and Sciences so I'd like
to thank the academy for making this
possible and as amazing as it is that we
can look at what was happening under the
ice sheet 50 years ago this is still
just one more snapshot it doesn't give
us observations of the variation at the
annual or seasonal scale that we know
matters now there's some progress here
too there these recent ground-based
radar systems that stay in one spot so
you take these radars and you put them
on the ice sheet and you bury a cache of
car batteries and you leave them out
there for months or years at a time and
they send a pulse down into the ice
sheet every so many minutes or hours so
this gives you continuous observation in
time but at one spot so if you can pair
that imaging to the 2d pictures provided
by the airplane this is just one
vertical line and this is pretty much
where we are as a field right now we can
choose between good spatial coverage
with airborne radar sounding and good
temporal coverage in one spot with
ground-based sounding but neither give
us what we really want both at the same
time and if we're going to do that we're
going to need totally new ways of
observing the ice sheet and ideally
those should be extremely low cost so
that we can take lots of measurements
from lots of sensors well for existing
radar systems the biggest driver of cost
is the power required to transmit the
radar signal itself so it'd be great if
we were able to use existing radio
systems radio signals that are in the
environment unfortunately the entire
field of radio astronomy is built on the
fact that there are bright radio signals
in the sky and a really bright one is
our Sun so actually one of the most
exciting things my group is doing right
now is trying to use the radio emissions
from the Sun as a type of radar signal
so this is one of our field tests at Big
Sur that PVC pipe ziggurat is an antenna
stand some undergrads and my lab built
and the idea here is that we stay out at
Big Sur we watch the sunset and radio
frequencies and we try and detect the
reflection
the Sun off the surface of the ocean now
I know you're thinking there are no
glaciers at big surf and that's true but
it turns out that detecting the
reflection of the Sun off the surface of
the ocean and detecting the reflection
off the bottom of an ice sheet are
extremely geo physically similar and if
this works we should be able to apply
the same measurement principle in
Antarctica and this is not as
far-fetched as it seems the seismic
industry has gone through a similar
technique development exercise where
they were able to move from detonating
dynamite as a source to using ambient
seismic noise in the environment and
defense radars use TV signals and radio
signals all the time
so they don't have to transmit a signal
of radar and give away their position so
what I'm saying is this might really
work and if it does we're going to need
extremely low-cost sensors so we can
deploy networks of hundreds or thousands
of these on an ice sheet to do imaging
and that's where the technological stars
have really aligned to help us
there's earlier radar systems I talked
about were developed by experienced
engineers over the course of years at
national facilities with expensive
specialized equipment but the recent
developments and software-defined radio
rapid fabrication and the maker movement
make it so that it's possible for a team
of teenagers working in my lab over the
course of a handful of months to build a
prototype radar okay they're not any
teenagers they're Stanford undergrads
but the point holds that these enabling
technologies are letting us break down
the barrier between engineers who build
instruments and scientists that use them
and by teaching engineering students to
think like earth scientists and earth
science students who can think like
engineers my lab is building an
environment in which we can build custom
radar sensors for each problem at hand
that are optimized for low cost and high
performance for that problem and that's
going to totally change the way we have
survived Sheetz so like the sea level
problem and the role of the cryosphere
in sea level rise is extremely important
and will affect the entire world but
that is not why I work on it I work on
it for the opportunity to teach and
mentor extremely brilliant students
because I deeply
that teams of hyper talented hyper
driven hyper passionate young people in
soft most of the challenges facing the
world and that providing the
observations required to estimate
sea-level rise is just one of the many
such problems they can and will solve
thank you